guys this is the best birthday gift I've
ever gotten it's being here how are you
guys this is really exciting I feel like
as a fanboy being here with you too and
and Florentine going Oh ninjas what are
they gonna do dress up and pretend we
don't see them that's a TV show great
Brennan just getting upset over there my
girlfriend and I broke up two weeks ago
and so that's been right before your
birthday so she did Christmas we broke
up we broke up we were just we were just
in Miami her she's from Venezuela her
sisters in Venezuela and I think she
realized she missed family she lost her
job and then I think she was sitting
there looking at me going am I going to
spend the rest of my life I mean there
must've been like jest with you going
is this really what I'm gonna hitch my
wagon to she is jokes and talks about
ninjas how long three years and she
broke up with you I I ended up I think
she was willing she was just saying like
I need a commitment are we going to have
a baby
oh she was willing to stay she was
willing to say but she's like we have to
have issues 44 I'm 40 I just turned 47
today and she's like whether we have a
baby now you wanted a little ninja
she wanted never had a baby she's never
had a baby forty boys a little old I'm
not it's probably gonna come out with a
helmet that's probably a logically
that's what it was looking like - it
wasn't looking too promising so as you
know you're looking at a lot of money a
lot of heartbreak and the potential for
one to come out she's moving you like
just over with a guy 45 I think I think
she's gonna leave LA go be with her
family and find something new to do and
not date a comic and yeah plus I never
met her but I think I think you can do
better
you're a catch Maddie I see you're
speaking a handsome guy and you get a
paycheck and you know it's interesting
what's interesting and I will ask you
guys because other than Sam your
single regular yeah yeah yeah you're
going through a rough time yeah my life
loves in my life but I've been single
for years do this do you I feel part of
it is our job that we spend so much
times in such an unstable job where we
have an unhealthy focus on ourselves
that no relationship can withstand yeah
unless you have a girl who's so secure
with you going out and spending all your
time other girls on the road did you you
guys you guys have been through it so
I'm more curious to hear from you what
it was like when you you know you have a
pregnant woman at home and you're trying
to make that work while you're on the I
felt that every relation I read on TMZ
that was not Florentines issue yeah Jim
did not have that he had other issues I
read no no you just deal with it like
okay this is my part of my life now so I
got a pregnant wife I'm married then I
just know my career's over
okay that's it right yeah I just feel at
that point I mean but then I feared then
I feel like the resentment right then
you resent the woman you resent the
child like Sam I feel like he's it's a
mitzvah for him right this little child
here and no yeah that jess is locked to
him no I love the kid I love my wife but
she also like understood my lifestyle
from the beginning so you know that was
always part of the under tray she never
kid herself into thinking that like okay
sure we'll do this for five or ten years
and they'll be off doing something else
like it's always been like no no no she
was getting exactly I kind of feel like
a girl I don't know if you where a girl
will get with you and back this is this
is cute your lifestyle like I I you know
I think it's cool you're traveling and
it's fun to come once in a while but as
they start to get serious go you're not
going to do this yes nice to come
they don't mind my lifestyle but I think
it's the fact that like your lifestyle
also makes you less likely to be
interested in their lives like their
lives are kind of boring in comparison
with a regular job I can't give a [ __ ]
about your job not to be arrogant I
don't care yeah that's definitely it
because I remember this grow as a
schoolteacher and like at a Friday if I
took off she being like an Applebee's
would you know our teachers and they'll
be talking shop food home no no one even
wanted to eat it no but and I just felt
like I had a play I'm like I don't give
a [ __ ] what's going on in their world
with teachers and stuff I'm sure they
wouldn't want to set the Comedy Cellar
table the job of comic but it's much
more interesting because it's what
people pay to see yeah I'm Brandon I'm
fascinated by you because you just like
this Catholic miserable guy who's torn
between you really love your wife
you love your kids and you have this
guilt Abney guy who's like but I'd much
rather be on my own no here's the thing
yeah I wouldn't like to be on my own but
here's the thing like not be way Sam
yeah Sam as you know you know Sam has it
I want what Sam has like a steady job
right off the traveler because that's
what women want like what like when I go
out on Saturday night to do to do gigs
even in New York my wife I can tell
she's a little bit resentful because
everybody else goes out on Saturday
night where she's stuck with the [ __ ]
kids right and she's like oh at least
you go out and your job social you got
to have a good time but it's true I
think it comes from you coming in like
two seconds your little bird starts to
leave the nest and do this WWE stuff
okay yeah he's going to be traveling I
mean seems a little bit remember come on
special delivery like you were a little
bird once yeah you're right and I'm
saying not not to diminish the fact
you're a full-blown red breasted
Cardinal now last professional
broadcaster the last professional
brought WWE I imagine you're gonna be
traveling a lot more and it's just
nervous about that I know I mean I know
I mean she'd rather I be at home but
like I'm done like one weekend a month
if that and and she's fine with it
because I'm on w/e TV are you asking if
I happy he's travelling yes
we don't know we're used to it no no no
saying like I I think that's part of the
relationship though is just is just
physically proximity and the more you
travel we don't like it when you're
sleeping somewhere else do you like time
even with FaceTime with everybody I know
you're not in bed with someone hidden in
your saturnine but how much do you
travel I'm gone like the next 7 weeks
Wow no a lot yeah yeah yeah you think he
didn't bang any new chicks that you're
single I'm 47 I'm on Hallmark TV you're
on TV I'm on the wrong TV I'm on the TV
where people like we pray for you and
make you biscuits
can you imagine but but like you're not
getting in their pants seeing handsome
Basie voice muscular six foot five Matt
Iseman and single yeah it's probably
better I mean I have the handsome
muscular bass voice part I'm just not
doing yeah that kind of fun different
spirits probably single in your life you
could get laid without even being famous
and there are two things one is I am at
the point where I'm also realistic you
know I'm 47 I'm like if I want a family
which I do I don't have too many years
left to [ __ ] around why not with that
girl I just it came down like you know
the one where you're like I was going to
spend the rest of my life with right
just couldn't say yes well she was at
the age I don't want to put a 44 year
old woman like
it would have been a nightmare because
my wife was 36 or 35 when she got
pregnant I'm just saying like the
doctors were like in a even at 35 for
the first kid they get real nervous
we're like you know this was gonna be
like the Six Million Dollar Man we have
a technology but more importantly no
matter what man says it's all coming
back to possible pregnancy complication
baby super teens right those venezuelan
they do but the you know the problem is
is just if you're mature enough for it
you know like are you pointing ma well
because you seem to be mature enough oh
[ __ ] miserable but I can't leave my
kids so I'm gonna make this work and in
a way it's like no I mean I do love my
kids I don't want some other douchebag
around my kids so I you know whatever it
when I think it works yeah when I go
through times where I'm like I you know
I'm not happy whatever I just I just
[ __ ] about in my pocket or whatever it
is to you for making it work cuz I think
I think what we didn't realize is our
parents probably had tough times they
just damn radio shows to [ __ ] about it
and we didn't know you're right cuz like
I don't think a relationship is supposed
to be easy hence me bailing on it but
well you know I mean I don't know how
she can not be happy with you so this
was my birthday but I bar trolling the
Panda gummy bears cuz I heard he was he
took a little heat for the MS on Friday
which by the way watching that live I
couldn't tell if it was real or what I
don't know I didn't see it so like on
Friday the MS came in but he wasn't
booked cuz I just got a text right
before right before I went on the air
saying like them did anybody reach out
to you about them is from WWE and I was
like no and they and I already other
guests booked and everything but I was
like are you asking if I'll take him
because yeah I'll take the measuring
time but you know he's got to fit in
between this time because these other
guests are coming in blah blah blah so I
guess they had to rearrange the missus
schedule and then he wanted like the
publicist
want to take any heat so the Miz asked
am i doing sam show and instead of them
telling them is well we didn't reach out
to him and ask him because then they had
to rearrange their schedule they said
Sam said he was busy
so his publicist lied unless to miss
somebody [ __ ] right Jim loves
publicists so this is the Miz stormed in
here and we it's up on the YouTube
channel because it's really funny the
Miz stormed in here and started
demanding to know like what I was so
busy doing and he just seemed he came
across as very pissed but he also he was
cutting a problem he's also cutting a
problem wearing my pajamas just wearing
a sweatshirt he was Thomas right that's
his point problem but it was it was a
good work because now I'm aware of
Mondays 25th Raw right and I'm aware
that I'm gonna find out tonight if he
was really pissed or nobody's I'm gonna
see him so well so he could just he
could have just been doing that too
could been it's good radio though so
it's great right in the middle did you
tell him that you were not too busy for
him well yeah but you know I also like
to like when there's trouble I don't
like to avoid it necessarily yeah so
when he was like what were you so busy
doing that you couldn't talk to me and
so there it is you you're dressed like
some [ __ ] somebody from Whoville it's
a red sweater no but it doesn't fit your
arms ready grips your floral you could
not pick a more opposite man to have on
your [ __ ] yeah oh well I got it for free
the medium Jimmy you picked an opposite
man to have in your body you might be
too old to have a kid man you know cuz
by the time we meet somebody and then
you know get along with her and 4646 oh
you don't want to be that [ __ ] guy 62
years old at a [ __ ] t-ball game and
then he's gonna want a place which is
your grandkid right soccer and back yard
seemingly questionable genes that's
kid there's no play you know at 62 you
can be playing soccer with him as friend
you'll be fine at 47 you'll be fine just
get a younger woman a young kids with
your I'm sure among this group there are
many younger women waiting around for us
oh yeah yeah you know just want a piece
of me there might be you're out of shape
one of the former ninjas Kacy Catanzaro
coming over to the WWE and you know I it
was in my best I brought you a gift
because hey our show Team USA which is
on the USA Network and which is now
American Ninja Warrior versus ninja
follows Tuesday night smackdown it so I
saw you love it last year we got to go
to Louisville
Tuesday night smackdown and the WWE is
an unbelievably well-oiled machine to
see them on a Tuesday night in
Louisville have 12,000 fans in an arena
for a live show that they could have
been home and watching sure but but the
energy there was crazy and then they
spun it around immediately for the hour
they're gonna be private show the nitro
or something for the 205 yeah just
seeing like the machinery behind this
you know with those LED screens and then
they're like tomorrow night we're in
wherever then that's just to ducky yeah
it is
it is it is a grunt I mean it is a
monster non-stop comedy tour it's
amazing yeah it's amazing so when you do
Stan you do stand-up right I didn't know
you did stand it yeah I know work with
you I just knew you as a as a TV how's
that stand up for like 20 years actually
the first time I did stand-up I was in
med schools I was doing it here in New
York you're done there too right I'm a
doctor telling you about a [ __ ]
[ __ ] babies you already know this
you can't get laid you're [ __ ]
handsome actor who knows how to work a
[ __ ] because you're a doctor and you're
saying yours at school how are you
working what kind of I remember I was an
internal matter
unless there's a general practitioner
but I remembered they were doing Anatomy
and the woman would they had a female
doctor talking about the anatomy and she
referred to it as the [ __ ] instead of
the clitoris and everybody every you
know because we're guys we laughed
thicker tell me this we were talking
about this before you came in somebody's
been calling the hotline we were we were
talking about this before you came in it
might be my mommy
he said Brennan was he's been
complaining about the plight of the
white man a lot and right now it's
impossible to be a white man which to me
it's it's been pretty easy really white
man it's that tough but Brennan says
it's because I don't understand because
I'm not in the streets and that you
would get it that it might know it good
no I was joking he of course he won't
get it because he's like a [ __ ] alpha
white dude tall he's got he's a doctor
like if he's on it let me just say when
the subject of white men come up I have
no comment you want to keep a low
profile I'm just saying like when you
just stand them now like women or met
women looking like oh really this this
is what's interesting to me is again I'm
I'm a very clean comedian but I love
like a guy like Doug Stanhope or you
know Jimmy if you're going on talking
about some of your stories with friends
of to your questionable gender and I I'm
a firm believer of like a comics should
be able to tell there's it's like South
Park either everything's fair game or
nothing's fair game and I think it's a
scary time for people who earn their
living with words and again my comedy I
usually go nowhere near the edge but you
just see people getting chastised and
seeing people losing careers for tweets
or for comments taken out of context and
and it and it really goes back you said
something that I think really was
profound about like if an actor goes on
SVU and plays a rapist no but
thinks that person is a rapist but if a
comedian makes a commentary a social
commentary joke about rape in which you
may ironically say of course I rape as
clearly started by context then sarcasm
people go Jim Norton's a rapist yeah
well what do you think no you're not
that guy that just get mad at the idea
that you joked about right yeah Plus of
your rapist you're not going to tell
strangers your rapist rape that's true
you know I just don't does no one know
people are walking out I've been on the
road always really going on and no one's
walking out of a club but people aren't
walking out all of a sudden rented like
oh my god he did this joke did that
that's always been going on you hope
people know and do their research like
know what you're coming to I think at
this point I just want to go into a
comedy club and laugh and they don't
give a [ __ ] about that no you know the
worst is when you get it like it you go
to the Comi cellar they you know they
have the big room the village on the
ground they get big groups of women
white women and they're just a nightmare
you know they just stay are there to
judge and they're just you know really
they don't like they don't like me I
mean people don't like me anyway but
tries to just look at me like you like
this guy this white guy he probably you
know he's probably done some assorted
[ __ ] because what guys have done a lot
of bad [ __ ] you know I've never seen you
do anything but kill every time I've
seen you onstage you [ __ ] mermaid Bob
cuz my jokes are strong enough but I'm
saying like they don't like listen if I
follow Grier I might as well just
[ __ ] punch your mama to [ __ ] you know
what I mean because white women love
black dudes because they think they're
gonna say they're you know they're they
have a common enemy white dudes you know
what white dudes are shooting black
dudes and they're raping white women so
Sarah they see a black comedy go yeah we
know your struggle where I get up there
I'm like I'm like a [ __ ] creep and
I've never even done anything well cuz
you remind them of the [ __ ] boyfriend
they didn't hide or College things like
I'm talking about my wife your [ __ ] that
probably turned guy that never called
them back your that jerk and I know I
remember this [ __ ] I don't smile
enough now you got ass if you're a white
dude you got a smile I like Matt you're
gonna do fine like Jimmy Fallon all
these like alpha [ __ ] you better be
happy but I don't smile in no time maybe
I have some dark secrets but I don't but
I'm saying you wanna be a song-and-dance
man you're a miserable person and a lot
of times people don't like miserable
people like I don't want misery around
yeah yeah yeah exactly that cloud that
has nothing to do with anything used to
be okay but now you really got a chart
you just got to be charming and cuz
women are just like we don't have where
they've got the frigde pressure they got
the guy walking around with a black
cloud the likable black guy the [ __ ] you
carry around with you the likable black
guy has always been hard for a white guy
to follow yeah you know what it's always
been so it's not just that's worse I
don't know everybody happy and likeable
is harder to follow his Grier is funny
and he's also smile he's having a good
time up there he makes people feel
relaxed and like oh my god this is what
a comedian is he's in a good mood and
he's funny and he's me and Greer also
the audience doesn't feel like they're
being judged by Greer like they figure
he's like I'm he's an absolute male with
an opinion but he's not making them feel
shitty whereas you know Kevin why don't
you just change your outlook a little
bit why don't you realize exactly like
you're making a living as a comedian
that's a dream a lot of people have
right you get to be a podcast host you
get to leave that silly writecast
Network yeah unless it's still on there
I don't know you got a famous brother
Florentine with the dagger
really
where I'm really trying I'm working on
it actually I've been doing better since
I've been miserable like since I really
embraced my never not been miserable
embracing I'm trying to monetize this
[Laughter]
people respond to though is the
authenticity they really believe it in
okay so one minute you're saying that
you're it's costing you that it's bad
for you right now yes you're not allowed
to be miserable anymore the next minute
you're saying things are going better
for me now because they are they are
outside outside like if I go to a
generic comedy club like I just say to
seller because the seller that it's a
hip room they get they get like the
women I want to go see a hip comedy show
but they're but they're not a good
audience so they go there they go there
like their executives there they're like
you know executives at their job and
like I give a [ __ ] you can't talk like
that in my job hey let's not bring race
into this Brennan no I'm agree with me
he goes it's white women they're they're
they're trying to politely end the
conversation
ya know agreed that white women are
ruining franking comedy is now gonna
have a me to pin onstage you [ __ ]
cops and I was a doctor too right
choking on a plant could save their life
that's that's free [ __ ] right oh yeah
and also I have an NBC TV the NBC TV
show and a [ __ ] it just get fired from
the Hallmark Channel
yeah guys what happens they had a daily
show called home and family and it was
the feeling was you were part of the
family it's why I would go on as like
the medical expert or slash kind of guy
and they're like we don't have room for
you in the family in 2018 they called me
up in December are they gonna get I
thinking are you gonna be watching to
see who the new medical expert is ah no
probably not yeah I don't care
will you hurt heartbroken is it a lot of
money was it was it was the big money
gig at all but it was one of those gigs
where I really like the people Jeff
Antonopoulos was on it and some other
people Kym Douglas who does The Ellen
Show who were like no tonight she was
one of the original view members she was
the first woman fired off the view she
had a blonde one yeah watch it fired she
was a little young institution and you
know just I don't think she had the
respect for Barbara Walters okay man
jeanette being around girls looking like
him and he's a doctor and he knows how
to use words like in sushi mark hallmark
just said you're not part of the family
and that was it okay say [ __ ] you you're
not part of my family yeah I did I stole
stuff when I left good good but it was
it was a honestly was one of those
things Rose the money wasn't great but
it really was a fun run and you're just
feeling job you know enjoy we've got
season ten coming out we're doing a
spin-off show American ninja wearing
ninja versus a ninja that always
Smackdown in the spring i watch because
I think that I'm USA after s'more
accidentally yes Lee before I can reach
the channel live tour like an Ice
Capades are like the virus tour it could
be we were taking the course out live to
like Phoenix in San Diego and people
will be able to pay and go through the
Californian go ahead caller
Sam straight caller Stephanie go ahead
you Stephanie you're right I know what
you're saying go ahead yeah so I don't
personally know zero females that side
with black dudes against black men what
you said you know zero female to side
with black men yeah racist [ __ ] kind of
way I know you say you're saying that
they're not they don't do what Kevin is
saying they do you know just to go I go
black guys are saying - sorry grew it I
know what you mean so Kevin
so Stephanie you know if Kevin walked on
stage you're not gonna judge him go at
all what's this white guy gonna tell me
about relationships that's his point
where do you live Stephanie okay it's a
big state I mean I've been there it's a
big state so it probably depends on
where you live and what you're like you
know like if you live in an urban
[ __ ] City Los Angeles it's like women
are getting real [ __ ] snow D that's
all I'm saying
Kevin don't you think that women are
listening I'm saying really don't you
think Kevin for like that maybe that the
women aren't looking at you like oh it's
just another one of these
white men that maybe it's like you are
like clearly a like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
from the minute you start talking at the
same time though while we're talking
about stereotyping can you say have you
seen Kevin Brennan's act Mike because
here's the mark of a comedian I think a
comedian able to say something you
totally disagree with but be so funny
that you laugh at it despite that and
that's the goal of a communal area but
not Kevin don't you think that they just
think you're an [ __ ] because you're
an [ __ ] not because you're a white
man ago I'm trying it I don't go up like
I do
go ahead Stephanie I don't go I don't go
up start saying content all this [ __ ]
when I first go up there I try to win
him over but I can see the looking
around like it shit's changing alright I
mean if you think shits not changing you
know you're not paying attention cuz
like women are pissed women are pasted
on out all pissed to the same degree but
they are pissed and to some level yeah
but I feel do you feel there's some of
it though for us to be like I don't care
I'm gonna be so funny and say things
that are know or provocative and stand
behind it so much that despite the fact
you disagree with me I'm gonna make you
laughing I have no choice because I
can't get laughs by being a friendly guy
you still don't even see me I think
everyone has and I know you're a seller
I'm saying I'm saying I can't get less
being a friendly guy I'm not a
song-and-dance guy so I gotta do what I
do I can't all of a sudden change to
this to whatever climate I'm dealing
exactly though but like I tried doing a
roast and I bomb because I'm not
comfortable and I mean don't be like oh
yeah what are we going to Chuck E Cheese
for your birthday Iseman are we gonna
try to get you tickets
jim-jim sister wanted to come to ninja
warrior and he's like do you know I'm
like of course I know who you are will
you make fun of me this is great ninjas
little people pretending we can't see
him dancing on a horse what is this
elementary school recess
I got no problem with the show but but
I'm saying like it's it's that's who you
are it's like you gotta be like I can't
point Matt Matt sole point is I gotta be
Who I am and it's not as welcome as it
used not a bit big groups of women and
guys what any kind of big groups of the
same sex are always a [ __ ] nightmare
in a comedy club guy that won't shut the
[ __ ] no I think now guys want even more
like they want the [ __ ] they want the
funny human like if you're in San
Francisco listen it's just it's like
shits changing its me all this [ __ ] it's
like have these marches and [ __ ] all
these cities like it's not it by
accident like women are pissed and they
don't want to hear it from a white dude
right they it like so it affects how
they react to other things have you
talked to Louis since I have not no no
no I haven't spoken to him she watched
some women do you watch footage from the
women's March over the weekend a little
bit and then I came and I change the
track hey wait a min we get someone else
oh that thinks I found one I found one
they even come to hey Josh you're on the
phone with Kevin and Matt and Jim and
Sam and Jim yeah yes I was wondering
what did it ask Kevin if he ever
considered being a nice guy like his
brother Neil because he's really
successful when I've seen him do
interviews cuz like I'll search him out
on YouTube sure and I'll see him do
interviews and like he's like a
respected voice in comedy is is also
heavily medicated you know yeah is that
bad though yeah I mean I can't be
heavily medicated because then then I
then I have no act right I mean if I'm
all like how come he can do it because
he's been heavily medicated for years I
human Neil honestly get along or not I
mean we got a long winner you know when
I was his older brother but now I'm not
older than him so I'm more like his dad
you just not like that he's successful
he just jealous of his success not
really I just I just think he's a star
[ __ ] [ __ ] and so that puts a little
[ __ ] crank in our relationship
says he's the star [ __ ] who say
absolute star [ __ ] crystal a exotic
[ __ ] he's never talking to Chad Zuma
he's talking to Chris [ __ ] deal
whoever's the hottest comic daddy's in
the presence of that's if he was right
here never tell you'd be talking about
those they say success attracts success
so maybe he says that a fortune cookie
[ __ ] yourself maybe his success is
attracting other successful because
people think like oh he helps you pal
but right also maybe can help me but he
hasn't done [ __ ] since then that's that
[ __ ] [ __ ] special three mites that he
stole from that other guy who did two
Mike's
oh that's right Joker Mordor I can't
wait for that drop look at his brother I
don't know two Mike's
I've heard of that Jeff Marty's - do you
remember Jeff mortar I don't know yes he
used to do a thing with two Mike's he
would do he was talking to I didn't see
three Mike no it was it three different
perspectives or three to the faces left
at three different mics and Jeff Martyr
talked to too much so Neil what he did
was Neil added a mic and that's
considered revolutionary my mom loved it
my mom cuz my mom's a [ __ ] - so
she's on Neil side who do you guys hold
in high regard like I mean honestly
amongst the communities there are there
ones who you feel like of your
contemporaries okay the ones have gone
before like not prior not them but like
of the people now do you guys who do you
guys think Dave Attell probably right I
would say Bob Kelly nearly always
interests me is the comic who comics
respect Colin Quinn call including David
teller - the most Chappelle is on that
level of Fame but he's right he's
respected by comedians he's a
brilliantly funny like these guys are
all respected what about heaven can I
just make it as a comedian because you
were just talking about as a person no
one likes him but he as a comedian
people think he's very funny unlike the
people you're around is there some one
way you're like that guy's that guy's
amazing
well I was best friends with a towel for
a
for a long time so what happened I don't
know he just say once I got married it
was like imagine what's the common
denominator and all of these nobody
whatever so I'm not the friendliest guy
but I like a lot of comics you know I
mean it's not like a David Tao stopped
hanging out with you after you got
married no well what's he stopped
drinking he was but he was a bit of he's
a bit of a dweeb you know so when I get
married and when I get married I'm gonna
yeah then Florence I think floor I think
these guys are great you know I mean
genuinely I genuinely see comics and I
go like like I'm doing a white lives
matter comedies comedy tour we only have
one date so far but at Village
Underground no but I like Mike Becky
Owens on a show Christy's to find a both
fun both guys that kill and really hard
to find Bergen Jean or funny yeah
they're great
Florentines great I'm sorry I'm just
fast because I think you guys are to me
this is you guys are the ones who are in
the trenches out here in New York well
I've always admired Jim Jim's prolific
what is material a guy turns over a new
hour every year and it's always amazing
and I've always been fascinated he did
the morning show but would be out every
night I do things but none of them
particularly well I was just I was in
Nashville I was doing I went to
Nashville to go to like some press and I
saw Joel McHale there oh yeah and McHale
was out doing he was doing saying he's
sold out both nights because he's
getting ready for a special and he just
the next day he announced he's bringing
back the soup like for Netflix and
talking to Joel oh is that thing of yeah
but it probably won't work and my
special is probably gonna suck and I'm
like oh you have anything else like well
after this I'm going to Sundance I've
got two movies and then I don't think
it's false you know it is I know the guy
is false
[Laughter]
unbelievable drive where you would like
finish the show sleep for two hours and
they go out for six hours and then sleep
for four hours because you're like I'm
never gonna give up stand up and I'm
never gonna give up a radio and you're
so afraid that something is gonna fall
through you got to do everything because
you're afraid they're gonna be taken
away I sincerely believe McHale was one
of those guys who's like that neuroses
that drives investors no you know you're
not doing good even if the more the
better you're doing yeah the more fake
humble you have to be hey yeah we're
gonna go to Barrett we have a couple my
celebrity wants to thank Matt for coming
on the show yesterday
what's up Baris hey Matt thank you so
much for coming on the show saving
saving this drowning radio program from
Brennan's compliment cam it's very funny
you know like Kevin no Mike it's so
heavy
I've like tried to prevent myself from
changing the show many times today in a
car 14 for bread 12 noon all right
thanks ever show down yeah thank you for
being a friend